hi everyone
uh welcome to cs224n lecture nine
uh self-attention and transformers uh if
i am not able to be heard right now
please someone send a message in the
chat because i can't see anyone um uh
but uh i'm excited to get into the
content for today um we'll be talking
about self-attention and transformers uh
let us dive into
the lecture plan and we'll talk about
some some sort of uh to-do's for the
course as well so we'll start with where
we were
back
last week with recurrence recurrent
neural networks and we'll talk about a
movement from recurrence to
attention-based nlp models we talked
about attention and we're going to just
go all in on attention um we'll
introduce the transformer model which is
a particular type of attention-based
model that's very popular
you need to know it you're going to
learn it we'll talk about some great
results with transformers and then some
drawbacks and variants and sort of very
recent
work on improving them so some reminders
before we jump in
assignment 4 is due
the mid-quarter feedback survey is due
tuesday february 16th
you get
some small number of points for doing
that and we really appreciate your
feedback on what we've done well what we
can improve on
and then
final project proposal is also due uh
one note on the proposals part of the
goal of the proposal is to uh you know
or i'd say the main part of the goal of
the proposal is to give you feedback on
the idea that you have presented and
make sure that it is a a viable
a viable option for a final project and
make sure we kind of recenter if not and
so we want to get feedback to you very
quickly on that okay
all right so with that let's start
in on the content of this week's lecture
so
we were in this place in nlp as of last
week where we had recurrent neural
networks sort of for a lot of things
that you wanted to do
so it's around 2016 and the strategy if
you want to build a strong nlp model is
you have you know sentences that you
need to encode and you have like a
bi-directional lstm say um and you know
maybe it looks a little bit like this
pictographically
and maybe it's a source sentence in a
translation for example we saw a machine
translation and then you define your
output which is maybe a sequence of
words which is the target uh you know
translation that you're trying to
predict or maybe it's a parse tree or
it's a summary
and you use
an lstm uh with one direction
uh to generate it
and this works really well uh we did we
used these these architectures to do all
kinds of interesting things um but one
thing that we said we talked about is
information sort of bottleneck that
you're trying to encode maybe a very
long sequence and sort of the very last
vector in your or in one vector in your
encoder and so we use the tension as
this mechanism to take you know
a representation of from our decoder and
sort of look back and treat the encoded
uh representations as a memory that we
can ba that we can reference and sort of
pick out what's important to any given
time
and that was attention and this week
we're going to do something slightly
different
so we we learned about sequence to
sequence models the encoder decoder way
of thinking about problems
more or less in order to deal with this
idea of you know building a machine
translation system that's end to end
differentiable
right and so uh this is sort of a really
interesting way of thinking about
problems uh what we'll do this week is
different we're not trying to motivate
sort of an entirely new way of thinking
about
problems like machine translation
instead we're going to take the building
blocks that we were using uh you know
recurrent neural networks and we're
going to spend a lot of trial and error
in the field trying to figure out if
there are building blocks that just work
better across a broad range of problems
we're going to slot the
new thing in for recurrent neural
networks and say you know voila maybe it
works better
and so
i want to take us on this sort of
journey
to
self-attention networks and we'll start
with some problems with recurrent neural
networks so we spent a bit of time
trying to convince you
that our current neural networks were
very useful
now i'm going to talk about reasons why
they can be improved
so um
we know that recurrent neural networks
are enrolled left to right
quote in air quotes it could be right to
left as well
so what does this mean
our current neural network
encodes linear locality
right so once i'm looking at tasty
in this in this phrase i'm about to look
at pizza or if i'm going in the other
direction once i look at pizza i'm about
to look at tasty and so it's very easy
for their meanings for their presence in
the sentence to affect the meaning to
affect the representation of the other
word um
and this is actually quite useful
because nearby words frequently do
influence each other that's practically
one of the things we talked about with
the distributional hypothesis as encoded
by something like word to back
but if words are distant linearly they
can still
interact with each other this is
something that we saw in dependency
parsing
so if i have say the phrase the chef
notice chef bolded here i'm running a
recurrent neural network over this
and then you know the chef who and then
i have this long sequence that i'm going
to that i'm going to encode
and then the word was
right maybe it is the chef
who was but in between i have o of
sequence length many steps of the
computation that i need to get to before
chef and waz
can interact
right and so in the middle
things might might go wrong
you know maybe it's hard to learn uh
things with um
where they should interact so in
particular um it might be hard to learn
long distance dependencies because we
have gradient problems we saw that lstms
propagate gradients better than simple
rnns but not perfectly
and so if chef and waz are very far it
becomes hard to learn that they should
interact and the linear order of words
is sort of baked into the model right
you have to unroll the rnn
throughout the sequence
and it's not really the right way to
think about
sentences necessarily um at least you
know linear order isn't really how how
how uh sentences are kind of structured
um
and so you know here you have chef
and then you've got all this sort of
computation in the middle all those
applications of the recurrent weight
matrix uh before you allow it to
interact with was and again sort of
dependence is o of sequence length
and then you got the word was okay a
second problem is very related uh this
is the lack of parallelizability
so this is going to be a huge refrain
now that we've gotten to the
transformers lectures is
parallelizability um it's what you get
from your gpu and it's what you want to
exploit so so um
when you run an rnn
you have
o of sequence length many
unparallelizable
operations
and so while you have a gpu they can
kind of chunk through a bunch of
independent operations at once
you're unable to sort of do them all at
once because you have this explicit time
dependence in their current equations
in particular you know a future rnn
state down the line can't be computed
until you've computed one that's earlier
on and this inhibits training on very
large data sets so let's take a look at
this on rolling an rnn
if this is say the first layer layer of
an rnn or an lstm maybe it doesn't
depend on
effectively anything you can just
compute it immediately
and then the second layer so this is a
you know stacked set of two lstms the
second layer depends on the first layer
here
in
the time dimension though
this uh
this
cell here depends on this so you've got
a one and then you know this depends on
this so you got one so you have you know
at most sorry at least two things that
you need to compute here before you can
compute the value of this uh cell
likewise three here and with the
sequence length it grows with o of the
sequence length so so here i have been
unable to even try to compute this value
when i get here because i had to sort of
do all of this first so i can't
parallelize over the time dimension
and this inhibits training on very large
data sets
um
okay so and then i guess chris or ta is
feel free to stop me with the question
if it feels like that's the right thing
to do
um
okay so
and you can see how it's a related
problem right it's really directly
related to the recurrence of the model
uh the thing that we thought was really
useful now is being
problematic
okay so so
what i'm trying to say with that is uh
we seemingly want to replace recurrence
as the building block itself so let's go
through some alternatives and we've seen
each of these alternatives in the class
so far we'll start with word window uh
sort of building blocks for our nlp
models if we wanted to replace our
encoders and our decoders with something
that sort of fit the same
goal but had different properties
so a word window model will aggregate
local context right we saw this with our
sort of word window classifiers that
we've built already
you take a local context of words you
use it to
to represent information about the
center word this is also known as
one-dimensional convolution uh we'll go
over this in depth later in the course
right now we'll consider it as word
window uh contexts
so the number of unparallelizable
operations with these word window uh
building blocks does not grow with the
sequence length and here's sort of a a
picture of that you have the embedding
layer say so you can embed every word
independently
right so you don't need to know the
other words surrounding it in order to
pick the right embedding dimension out
and so these all have sort of zero
dependence in this sort of
hand wavy notion of how much uh
paralyzability is there is
now you can walk a word window
classifier on top of each one to build a
representation of the word that takes
into account its local context
but in order to apply it to this word h1
i don't need to know anything sorry i
don't need to have applied it to h1 in
order to apply it to h2 likewise in
order to apply a word window
contextualizer to ht
i can just look at its local window
independently
and so again
none of these have a dependence in time
and i can keep stacking layers like this
right so this can look
like an encoder right an encoder like
our lstm encoders um if i didn't allow
you to look at the future by just
cutting off the window it could look
like a decoder for language models and
this this is nice
and we get this beautiful you know uh o
of one dependence in time right no
dependence at all in the time dimension
that's an improvement but there are some
problems so what about long distance
dependencies right this is this is why
we said we wanted to use recurrent
neural networks it's because they would
do better at encoding long distance
dependencies
it's a problem just like it was a
problem before but by stacking word
window layers we can get to wider longer
contexts
so if you have some sort of window size
and then you stack two layers
uh so red states here interac state kind
of how you can look how far away you can
look in order to encode h k
right so in the embedding layer um
you have these sort of words here so so
this is the last layer this top layer of
the word window classifier here's the
embedding of hk at the output of your
encoder
and so it looks at you know the local
five words because that's the window
size and then as well you know
the farthest word over here has also
looked a couple of words away
right so if you stack these and stack
these and stack these
without growing the window size at all
at any given layer
you can look pretty far and actually
there are tricks you can use to look
even farther but you still have this
sort of at least in principle problem
where you've got a word like this h1
and you can see how it's in blue
and you know with these two layers of
the network
i don't know anything about h1 at all
when i'm building up the representation
of hk over here
i could solve that by adding another
layer in depth but you know in principle
you always have some finite field
um
so this is
you know actually pretty useful uh these
you know uh word window kind of
contextualizers and we will learn more
about them later uh and there's sort of
a lot of this effort that i talked about
at the beginning of the class was
actually sort of partly deciding which
of when the word window stuff
convolutional is called stuff or
attention and attention has won out for
the time being um and and so yeah what
about attention so what why could it be
useful as like a as a fundamental
building block instead of sort of sugar
on top of our lstms
um so just to
recall some of the intuitions of
attention
it treats a word's representation as a
query
and it looks somewhere
and tries to sort of access information
from a set of values right so we had a
word representation in our decoder in
our machine translation systems the set
of values where all of the encoder
states for the source sentence
and
today we'll think about instead of
attention from the decoder to the
encoder we'll think about attention
within a single sentence
so just a very quick picture of it
you've got your embedding layer again
i'm putting the computational dependence
counts here so all of these sort of can
be done in parallel uh for the embedding
layer again
and now you're doing a tension right so
so you're kind of looking at every
single word in the embedding layer uh to
attend to this word
and um i'm emitting a bunch of arrows
here so these are all arrows all words
interact with all words and we'll get
deep into this today i promise but i
just wanted to sort of make this a
little bit
less dense looking of a graph and then
so in the second layer again all pairs
of words interact and this is all
parallelizable so you can't parallelize
in in depth right because you need to
encode this layer before you can do that
layer but in time it is parallelizable
so it checks that box
so again we have o of one sort of
computational
dependence
you know number of unparallelizable
operations as a function of sequence
length and uh as an added benefit right
uh the interaction distance between
words
is of one as well
so whereas before we had recurrent
networks where if you are far
so t is the last word in the sentence
you could have o of t
operations between you and a far away
word with attention you interact
immediately that's very first layer you
get to see your far away word and so
that's o of one and this ends up being
seemingly uh fascinatingly powerful and
we'll get into a lot of details
today
okay
so so this is sort of why attention
solves the two problems that we brought
up with recurrent neural networks but
with our empiricist hats on
it shouldn't be proof yet that you know
it should be a good building block and
in fact it takes a little bit of
thinking to think about how to turn
attention into a building block like
rnn's were
so let's start by
digging right into just the equations
for self-attention which again is
attention to where the
everything is looking within itself
we'll formalize this for you so we're
going to be talking all lecture today
about queries keys and values
our queries are going to be a set of t
queries each query is a vector in
dimension d
you can just think of them as just those
vectors right now
not worrying necessarily about where
they came from
uh we have a set of keys k1 the kt uh
again each vector k is in dimensionality
d
and we have some values each value is
going to be
also in dimensionality d and for now uh
we're going to assume that we have the
same number of all of them
that's not necessarily the case later so
in self-attention
in self-attention the keys queries and
values come from the same source of
information
the same sentence for example
um and so yeah in practice when they all
come from the same sentence right
there's going to be the same number of
all of them it's all going to be t in
practice you can have the numbers differ
so where do these come from we'll get
into the specifics of this later but but
for now think about the output of the
previous layer so imagine the output is
you know you have like the embedding
layer
right and that's the input to something
that's going to do self-attention think
of all of these uh outputs of the
embeddings as some vectors
x i
and now we can just say that the value
is equal to the q key
is equal to the query is equal to that x
i so we're going to use the same vectors
for all of them but labeling them as
keys queries and values i promise will
be very useful in how we sort of think
about what's going on and how we look at
the equations that implement this
so
self-attention
pretty generally
but with this dot product so develop
product self-attention here's just the
math
math is you compute key query affinities
and the dot product bit is the fact that
you're using the dot product function
here
so you take a dot product for all pairs
i and j
of q i
dotted with k
so that is a t by t matrix capital t
right by t matrix of affinities
those are scalar values
not bounded in size
next you compute the attention weights
we saw this as well using the softmax
function i've just written out the
softmax function here
so you know you exponentiate
the affinity and then you sum over
in this case right you're summing over
all of the
uh
keys so you've got a given query
and you're summing over all all the keys
for the normalization so where should
this query be looking remember you've
got t different queries that we're doing
this for uh here um and so for a given
query you sum over all the keys to get
your normalization constant normalizing
by that gives you a distribution over um
over the sequence length t so now you
have sort of a weight on all of the
sequence
indices
and again we do our weighted average
right so we've got our
weights for our average and then the
output right there's going to be one
output per query
the output is the weights for that
multiplied by the value vectors
right um so again if you set the keys
the queries the values to all be x
this makes sense but it's nice to have
the cues and the k's to know sort of
which thing is doing what you can think
of the query as being sort of looking
for information somewhere the key as you
know interacting with the query and then
the value is the thing you know that
you're actually going to you know weight
in your average and output
john a question you might like to answer
is so if now we're connecting everything
to everything how is this different to
using a fully connected layer
that's a great that's a great question
um
a couple of reasons uh one is that
unlike a fully connected layer you get
to learn
the interaction weights
uh well the interaction weights are
dynamic as a function of what the actual
values here are right so in a fully
connected layer you have these weights
that you're learning slowly over the
course of the training your network
that allow you to say sort of which
hidden units you should be looking at in
attention it's the actual interactions
between the key and the and the um
query vectors which are dependent on the
actual content that are allowed to vary
by time and so the actual strengths of
all the interactions of all the sort of
attention weights which you could think
of as you know connected to
the uh the weights in the fully
connected layer are allowed to change as
a function of the input a separate thing
is that the parameterization is much
different so you're not learning an
independent connection weight for all
pairs of things instead you have um
you're allowed to parametrize
the uh the attention as
you know these sort of dot product
functions between vectors that are
representations and you end up having
you know
the the the parameters work out
more nicely which we'll see later we
haven't gone into how we're
parametrizing these functions yet so
those are the two answers i'd say is one
is you have the sort of dynamic
connectivity and two is you know you
don't have just it has this inductive
bias that's not just connect everything
to everything feed forward
great
okay i think that's a very interesting
question uh
yeah so i'm glad you asked it
okay so
we've talked about self-attention now
the equations that go into
self-attention but uh can we just like
use this as a building block i mean you
know take all of your lstms throw them
out use the self-attention that we've
just defined instead why not well here's
a couple reasons uh why um so look at
self-attention as a building block so we
have some words in the sentence the chef
who
some stuff long sentence
food is the last word of the sentence
okay um
and you know they have an embedding and
from that you get your key query and
value we've said so far right that's the
same vector actually but you know key
query value key query value key create
value
um and you know we might stack them like
lstm layers so you have keqree value
perform self-attention on the keys
queries and values as we said
self-attention is a function on keys
queries and values so perform
self-attention now that you have these
get new keys queries values
and then perform self-attention again
look you know this looks a lot like
a lot like stacking lstms um
but it actually has a few issues as it
stands so we're going to need to go on a
journey to determine what's missing from
our self-attention and the first thing
is that self-attention is an operation
on sets
okay so for the equations that we had
before uh the self-attention equation
never referred to the indices
of k q or v
except to sort of say which which pairs
were interacting with each other it
doesn't know what the order of your
sentence is when it's computing though
the weights it has no idea
and so if i were to input this sentence
the chef who food
it would be the same as if i just
swapped the with chef and then swapped
to with the and it just would have no
idea
so already this is not going to work
because the order in which words appear
in sentences matters
so here's the first problem that we need
to work with so i'm gonna have a list of
barriers this is just the first got a
whole journey ahead of us and then we're
gonna have a list of solutions so we
need to represent the sequence order
somehow um we can't just lose that
information entirely because we wouldn't
know what order the words showed up in
so um
somehow if we're not going to change the
self-attention equations themselves we
need to
encode the order in the keys queries and
values and let the network sort of
figure it out um on its own so um think
about this we have t sequence indices
and we're going to bound t to some
finite constant
right so t is never going to be bigger
than something for us
and we call it t
and now we're going to represent the
sequence index as a vector so p i is
going to be the vector representing
index i and it's going to be in
dimensionality d just like our keys
queries and values
and so we're going to have one of these
for uh 1 to t
so don't don't worry yet about what the
pi are like how they're constructed
we'll get right into that um but think
about this it's easy to incorporate this
information into our attention building
blocks at the first layer if you let
tilda v tilde k tilde q be our old
values keys and queries
we can just add we could do other stuff
too
but in practice we just add so vi is
equal to v tilde i our orderless value
vector plus pi so this might be your
embedding uh you know your your
your embedding vector and then you add
the index that it's at to its vector
um and you know you might only do this
at the first layer of the network for
example so you do the same thing for the
query and the key so this is something
that you could do
in practice we do something slightly
different
but
this is something that you know now it
knows the order of the sequence because
if these pis you set properly somehow
then now the network is able to figure
out what to do with it so what's one way
of actually making this happen
one way of making this happen is through
the concatenation of sinusoids and this
was an interesting uh take when when the
first transformers paper came out they
used they used this method so let's dig
into it um so you have uh
varying wavelengths of sinusoidal
functions
in each of your dimensions so in the
first dimension if you have this sine
function with a given period
and then this cosine function with a
given period and then sort of dot dot
dot
you sort of change the periods until you
get to much much different periods and
what does it look like it looks like
that
so imagine here
in the vertical axis we've got the
dimensionality of the network right so
this is d
and then this is sequence length
and by just specifying you know and each
row is sort of one of these signs with
different with different uh frequencies
right
and you can sort of see how this is
encoding position these things have
different values
at different indices
and that's pretty cool i don't really
know how they thought of it immediately
um but but one cool thing about it is
this periodicity notion right the fact
that the sinusoids have periods that
might be less than the sequence length
indicates that maybe the absolute
position of a word isn't so important
right because you if the period is less
than the sequence length you you lose
information maybe about where you are of
course you've got the concatenation of
many of them
so that's a pro
maybe it can extrapolate to longer
sequences because again you sort of have
this repetition of values right because
the periods will
when they when they complete you'll see
that that value again the cons are that
it's not learnable i mean this is cool
but you can't there's no learnable
parameters in any of this and also the
extrapolation doesn't really work
so this isn't interesting and definitely
still done
but what's done more frequently now is
we you know what do we do we learn the
position representations from scratch so
we have uh
we're going to learn them from scratch
so let all the pi just be learnable
parameters so what we're going to do is
we're going to have a matrix p
that's going to be in dimensionality d
the dimensionality of our network again
by the sequence length so this is just a
big matrix right
of the size
here of this size effectively d by
sequence length
but every single value in that matrix is
just a learnable parameter
pros flexibility now you get to learn
what positions is sort of supposed to
mean according to your data uh end to
end so that's cool
cons
you definitely can't extrapolate to
indices outside one to t great because
you you set the size of this parameter
matrix at the beginning and you learned
them all now if you want to go beyond
position t
you know you just you have no way to
represent it effectively
but most systems use this this is super
useful
and
sometimes people try more flexible
representations of position because
again the absolute index of a word is
not sort of its natural
representation of its position in the
sentence and so people have looked at
the kind of the relative position
between words as well as position
representations that depend on
syntax but we're not going to be able to
go too far into those today
okay so that was problem one
right we just no matter what we did if
we didn't have a representation of
position there was no way we could use
self-attention as our new building block
and we've solved it with position
representations that we just sort of add
to the inputs
next um
we're going to see this problem that you
don't have non-linearities you know even
saying you know non-linearities you know
abstract features they're great deep
learning you know end-to-end learning of
of representations is awesome but right
now we're just doing weighted averages
um and so what is our solution going to
be i mean it's not going to be all that
complex
so all we're doing right now is
re-averaging vectors right so you've got
uh sort of the self-attention here and
if you just stacked another one you just
keep sort of averaging projections of of
vectors but what if we just add a
feed-forward network
for every individual word so within this
layer
each of these feed-forward neural
networks shares parameters
but it gets in just the output of
self-attention for this word as we
defined it processes it
and you know emits emits something else
and so you know you have output i from
self-attention which we saw slides ago
apply you know a feed-forward layer
where you take the output multiplied by
a matrix you know non-linearity other
matrix and the intuition here you can
think of at least is well you know
something like the feed forward network
processes the result of the attention uh
for each thing but
more fundamentally right you needed some
kind of non-linearity there and uh you
know a feed-forward network will will do
a good job okay so that that's another
problem solved easy fix
add a feed-forward network get your
non-linearity uh now your self-attention
output you can sort of process it have
that sort of depth increasing as the
layers of the network increase which we
know is is useful
another problem okay so bear with me on
this one
we don't want to look at the future when
we're doing language modeling
right so language modeling you're trying
to predict words in the future
and with a recurrent model it's very
natural right like you just
don't unroll it further once you've
unrolled a word to
unrolled your lstm to a given word
there's sort of no way to have
given it to the next word as well but in
self-attention we'll see that this is a
little bit trickier so we can't cheat
and look at the stuff we're trying to be
predicting because then we would train
networks that were totally useless so
what are we going to do
we're going to mask
masking is a word that's going to keep
coming up we're going to mask the future
in self-attention
so
in particular this is important when we
have decoders right one of the reasons
why we could use bi-directional lstms in
our encoders was that we could see the
whole source sentence in neural machine
translation but when we're predicting
the output sentence right we can't see
the future if we want to train the model
to do the actual prediction so to use
self-attention in a decoder you need to
mask the future
one thing that you could do is you could
just every time you compute attention
you change the set of keys
and values this should be keys and
values to only include past words so
you're sort of dynamically changing the
stuff that you're attending over but
that doesn't let us do stuff with
tensors as well as as parallelizability
as we will see
so we don't want to do that instead
we're going to mask out the future words
through the attention weights themselves
so in math don't worry we'll get to the
sort of diagram but in math we had these
attention scores
and they were equal to just this dot
product before for all pairs
right
but now
only if the key
is strictly less than the key index
is strictly less than the um this should
be i only if the key index is strictly
less than the query index so this would
be j
less than i uh should we let the network
look at the word and it should be
negative infinity otherwise so we don't
let you look at the output so let's go
to the picture for encoding the words
that we'll see here so maybe you have a
start token
you want to decide this is your whole
sentence now you want to decide which
words in the sentence
you're allowed to look at when making
your predictions
so i want to pre i want to predict the
first word
and uh in order to predict the i'm not
allowed to look at the word the i'm also
not allowed to look at any of the future
words
i am allowed to look at the word start
so this sort of block is is uh not
shaded here
in order to put the word chef i can look
at start and the right start the but not
chef naturally or the word that comes
after it and likewise for the other
words so you can see this sort of
this matrix here right so we just want
to make sure that our tension weights
are you know zero
everywhere here and so in the affinities
calculation we add negative infinity
to all of these in this big matrix
and that guarantees that we can't look
to the future
okay so now we can do big matrix
multiplications to compute our attention
as we will see
um
and we sort of don't worry about looking
at the future because we've added these
negative infinities
and that's the last that's the last
problem with self-attention sort of
that's
comes up fundamentally as like what do
we need for this building block
you have you didn't have an inherent
notion of order now you have a good
notion of order or at least something of
a notion of order you didn't have
non-linearities add feed forward
networks
and then you
didn't want to look at the future you
add the masks for the decoders
so you know self-attention is the basis
of any self-attention-based building
block hello
position representations are useful
non-linearities are good uh you don't
have to use a feed-forward network right
like you could have just done
other stuff i guess but you know in
practice actually it's really easy to
parallelize these feed forward networks
as well so we end up doing that um and
then the masking
you know yeah you don't want information
to leak
from the future to the past in your
decoder
so so let me be clear we haven't talked
about the transformer yet
but this is all you would need if you
were thinking like gosh what do i need
in order to build my self-attention
building block we'll see that there are
a lot more details in the transformer
that we're going to spend the rest of
the lecture going through um
and i
but i want you to sort of at least uh as
you're thinking about what's going to
come next after the transformer and how
you're going to invent it um think about
the fact that these are the things that
were necessary um and then the other
things end up being very very important
it turns out um but uh you know there's
a lot of design space here that hasn't
been explored yet
okay so let's talk about the transformer
model and i'm going to pause if there
are any this is a good question i can
take i can take it now
okay
so transformers
let's get to it
um
let's look at the transformer encoder
decoder blocks at a high level first
this should look a lot like the encoder
decoders that we saw
with the
uh
recurrent neural network machine
translation systems that we saw okay so
we have our word embeddings
we're going to add in our position
representations we saw that
and that's from our input sequence we'll
have a sequence of encoder blocks each
of them is called a transformer encoder
and then you know we have our output
sequence word embeddings position
representation again
um we have a transformer decoder
uh each and the last layer of encoders
is going to
be used in each layer of the transformer
decoder
and then we get some outputs some
predictions okay so this looks pretty
much the same at a very high level maybe
minus the fact that now we need to do
the position representation addition at
the very beginning
so now let's look at these blocks
themselves so the encoder and decoder
blocks what's left that we haven't
covered right because we could just put
the building blocks that we just came up
with in the first part of class in these
things right encoders we need our
self-attention our our feed forward
networks
we have our prison representations we
get the masking for the decoders right
we can just slot these in but it turns
out they wouldn't wouldn't work all that
well compared to transformers so what's
left
so the first thing is key query value
attention
this is a specific way of getting the k
q and v vectors from the single word
embedding right so instead of having k q
and v equal to x like the output from
the last layer we're going to do
something a little bit more
next is multi-headed attention we're
going to attend to multiple places in a
single layer and we'll see that that
gets us sort of kind of uh interesting
properties in the homework later on uh
but we'll talk a little bit about it
today and then there's a bunch of things
that just help with training these
seemed like they were very hard to train
at first a lot of these tricks are very
useful so we'll talk about residual
connections layer normalization and
scaling the dot product everything in
bullet point three here
tricks to help with training don't
improve what the model is able to do
but they're crucial in that they improve
the training process
so modeling improvements of both kinds
are really really important uh so you
know it's good that we're using
self-attention which is this cool thing
that had these properties but if we
couldn't train it it wouldn't be useful
okay
so here's how the transformer builds the
key query and value vectors
we have uh x1 to xt the input vectors to
our transformer layer okay and we're
trying to avoid the transformer encoder
here
so we have
you know one of these vectors per word
you can say and again each xi is going
to be a vector in dimensionality d
and here's how we compute the keys
queries and values
uh we're going to let each key ki which
we saw before
be equal to some matrix k times x i
where k is d by d
right so this is a transformation from
dimensionality d to dimensionality d
we're going to call this the key matrix
k
and we're going to do the same thing for
the queries okay so we're going to take
the x i multiply it by a matrix get the
query vector
and we'll do the same thing for v okay
so
you can just plug this in right now
instead of saying that all the k q and
the v are all the same as x they all are
slightly different because you apply a
linear transformation what does this do
well you know
you can think about it as like well you
know the matrices k q and v can be very
different from each other right and so
they sort of um
emphasize or allow different aspects of
the x vectors to be used in each of the
three roles right so we we wrote out the
self-attention equations with the three
roles to indicate the different things
are being done with each of them so
maybe you know k and q are helping you
figure out where to look
and so they should be a certain way they
should look at different parts of x and
then v the value
maybe you you want to pass along a
different information than the thing
that actually helps you
access that information
so um
so this is important how do we do this
in practice we compute it with really
big tensors um so we had our x vectors
which we've been talking about sort of
word by words where you had the sequence
x i x 1 to x t
um now we're going to represent them all
as a matrix x which is in our sequence
length by dimensionality so sequence
length by d
capital t by d
and now if we have the matrix for each
of our key query and value right we're
going to apply like we're going to look
at these things x k x q and x v which
are all of the same dimensionality as x
because of the d by d transformations
so how do we compute
self-attention we have our output tensor
which is the same dimensionality as the
input x
is going to be equal to soft max there's
a softmax of this matrix multiplication
which we'll get into
times the value vectors so the matrix
multiplication here is computing
affinities between keys and queries
we'll see and then here's our averaging
what does that look like pictorially
so you take the key query dot products
so this term here xq
xk transpose
is getting giving you all dot products
all t by t pairs of attention scores so
our e i j are in this matrix right here
it's t by t and this is just a big
matrix multiplication so you do the
matrix multiplication x q and then x k
and then you get all of the dot products
by through this okay so now you have
this big t by t set of scores that's
what we wanted um and now you can soft
max that directly as a matrix
and then you know do a matrix
multiplication here with x v in order to
give your output vector so this is
actually doing the weighted average
that we saw at the beginning of the
class
and this you know there's no for loops
here it's really beautifully what we say
vectorized um and it gives us our output
which again remember same dimensionality
t by d
okay so all periods of attention scores
then compute the averages by applying
the score the softmax of the scores to
the
x v
matrix um so that's it that's it for key
query value attention that's how you
know we implement it uh with tensors
next we'll look at the kind of the next
um
thing that ends up being quite important
for training transformers in practice
which is multi-headed attention so
transforming coder multi-headed
attention um so the question is what
what if we want to look at multiple
places in the sentence at once
it's possible to do that you know with
self-attention with normal
self-attention but think about this
where do you end up looking in
self-attention
you end up looking where the dot
products of x i your q matrix transpose
your key matrix x j is high so those are
those are sort of the x i j pairs sorry
those are the i j pairs that end up
interacting with each other
but maybe for some query for some word
in the out in for some word you want to
focus on different other words in the
sentence for different reasons
the way that you can encode this is by
having
multiple query key and value matrices
which all encode different things about
the xi they all translat learn different
transformations so instead of a single
queue a single k and a single v what we
get are a q sub l k sub l v sub l
all of a different dimensionality now so
by their dimensionality d by d over h
where h is the number of heads so
they're going to still apply to the x
matrix but they're going to transform it
to a smaller dimensionality d by h
um and then each attention head is going
to perform a tension independently it's
like you just did it a whole bunch of
times
right and so output l is equal to soft
softmax of you know here's your qk but
now it's in l form uh times xvl and now
you have uh sort of these indexed
outputs
and in order to sort of have the output
dimensionality be equal to the input
dimensionality and sort of mix things
around
combine all the information from the
different heads you concatenate the
heads so that's output one through
output h stack them together now the
dimensionality of this is equal to the
dimensionality of x again
and then we use a learned matrix y in
order to sort of do the mixing uh y is d
by d and that's the output of
multi-headed attention multi-headed
self-attention
and so because different so each head
gets to look at different things right
because they can all sort of uh the
linear transformations can you could say
focus on different parts of the x
vectors and um the value vectors also
get to be different as well
so pictorially this is what we had
before single headed attention you had x
multiplied by q in order to get x q
and what's interesting and you can see
this you know
you can see this from this diagram i
think is that multi-headed attention
doesn't necessarily have to be more uh
more work right we saw that the q k and
l uh vector uh sorry q k and v
matrices uh in multi-headed tension have
a lower output dimensionality so here's
two of them right here here's q1 and q2
the same size as q
and then you hit outputs xq1 and xq2
and so you're effectively doing the same
amount of computation as before
but now you're sort of doing you have
different detention distributions for
each of the different heads so this is
pretty cool
okay
so um
so those are the main
modeling differences right we did key
query value attention
that's how
that's how we got
the key queries and values from the x
vectors
and we saw how to implement that in the
matrices that we're looking at
and then we
looked at
the multi-headed attention which allows
us to look in different places in the
sequence
in order to
yeah have more flexibility within a
given layer
now we're going to talk about our
training tricks
these are really important it turns out
and so
yeah
uh thinking about them i think is
something that we don't do enough in the
in the field and so let's really walk
through them so residual connections
residual connections have been around
residual connections you can think of
them as helping the model train better
for a number number of reasons let's
look at what they're doing first our
residual connection looks like this so
you have a normal layer
x
in some layer i i is representing sort
of the layer and depth
in the network
uh so x i is equal to some layer of x i
minus one so you had right you had i
don't know what this layer is doing
necessarily
but uh this layer is a function of the
previous layer okay
and um so you got this so again i want
to want to abstract over what the layer
is doing but you just pass it through
a residual connection is doing something
very simple it's saying
okay i'm going to take the function i
was computing at my previous layer
before
and i'm going to add it to the previous
layer so now
x i is not equal to layer of x i minus 1
it's equal to x i minus 1 plus layer of
x i minus 1. this is it these are
residual connections
um and the intuition right is that like
before you started learning anything
sort of you have this notion that you
should be learning only how layer i
should be different from layer i minus
one
instead of learning from scratch what it
should look like so this value here
layer of x i minus one
should be something in some sense and
you have to learn how it's different
from the previous layer this is sort of
a nice inductive bias so so here you can
kind of represent it as you have this
layer x minus 1 goes to the layer
it also goes around and just gets added
in now think about the gradients right
we talk about about vanishing gradients
they're a problem
uh
you know the gradient of of this
connection here is beautiful right even
if everything's saturating
uh every all of your you know sigmoids
are saturating or your rails are all
negative so the gradients are all zero
right you get you get gradients
propagating back through the rest of the
network anyway through this connection
here that's pretty cool
turns out to be massively useful um
and just to take a quick visualization
this plot just never ceases to look
really really interesting um here is
sort of a a
visualization of a lost landscape so so
each sort of point in the 2d plane is
like a um
it's a sort of a setting of a parameters
of your network and then sort of the
z-axis is the loss of the network on
that it's being optimized for right and
here's a network note with no residuals
and you are stochastic gradient descent
and you sort of have to find a local
minimum and it's really hard to find the
nice local minimum
um and then with the residual network
uh you know
it's much smoother so you can imagine
how stochastic gradient descent is sort
of walking down here to this nice
very low local minimum this is a
paper that was trying to explain why
residual connections are so useful
so this might be an intuition that might
be useful for you uh so this is you know
this is the so-called loss
landscape so those are residual
connections
um
and it's they seem simple but a lot of
simple ideas end up being super useful
in deep learning
so
in layer normalization
um we're doing something sort of
similar we're trying to help the network
train better um but we're doing it via a
pretty different intuition
so
layer normalization is thought to say
at different times in my network when
i'm training it i'm doing the forward
pass there's a lot of variation
in what the forward pass looks like and
a lot of it is uninformative
and and that can that can harm training
but if we normalize within a layer
to a single to unit mean and standard
deviation then that sort of cuts down on
all this on all this sort of
uninformative variation
and the informative variation sort of
how the units were different from each
other uh is maintained
um so uh it's also thought that the
success of lara norman there's been a
lot of success of layer norm has been
due actually to
helping normalize the gradients of each
layer this is recent work
so let's talk about how it's implemented
so we're going to go back to x and not
going to index it here so just x is some
vector some word vector in in our
transformer
we're going to compute an estimate of
the mean
okay just by summing uh the the hidden
units we're going to compute an estimate
of the standard deviation
similarly so like you've taken a single
rd vector you just sum them you compute
the mean you compute this do you well
you estimate the mean you estimate the
standard deviation
okay
now
you
also potentially and this is optional
learn element element-wise gain and bias
parameters to try to sort of rescale
things if certain hidden units sort of
should have larger value in general or
should you know be be multiplicatively
larger in general um so these are
vectors in rd just like x was a vector
in rd
and then here's what layer normalization
computes
you have your output which is going to
be an rd
just like your input okay and you take
your vector x you
subtract the mean from all of them you
uh divide by
standard deviation oh
should have yeah sorry this shouldn't be
square root um and then you add an
epsilon that's small
in order if the standard deviation
becomes very small you don't want this
to uh the denominator to become too too
too small because then you get huge
numbers and then your network
goes to nan and doesn't train okay so um
so you have some sort of tolerance there
and then so you normalize there and then
our element-wise gain and bias now
remember this fraction
x is a vector everything is being done
sort of element-wise here right so this
is our d
and then you have this element wise
multiplication this hadamard product
with your gain
then you add the bias
whether the gain and bias are necessary
uh
is unclear this paper here suggests that
they're not helpful
but they're frequently used so
um sort of an engineering question at
this point and a science question
whether we can figure out why um in
general um
but yes that's layer normalization and
uh it ends up being very important in
transformers you remove it and they they
really don't train very well
okay so that's that's our second uh our
second trick
the third trick is
probably the simplest one but it's
useful to know uh and it's just
you can call it scaled dot product
attention
because we're going to scale the dot
products like so okay so um
what we're going to do is we're going to
we're going to have this this intuition
that our dimensionality d
in really big neural networks is going
to become very large
so maybe our hidden layer in our
transformer is a thousand or two
thousand or three thousand anyway it
gets it gets big um
and when the dimensionality becomes
large the dot products between vectors
tend to become large
so for example if you you know take the
dot product between two random vectors
in rd
it grows quite quickly their dot product
grows quite quickly now are the vectors
random in transformers well they're not
uniform random but you know you can
imagine there's sort of a lot of
variation and in general as the
dimensionality is growing all these dot
products are getting pretty big
and this can become a problem for the
following reason right we're taking all
these dot products directly and taking
them putting them into the softmax
so there's if there's variation in the
in the dot products and some of them are
very large
then the softmax can become very peaky
putting all most of the or you know yeah
most of its probability mass on a small
number of things which makes the
gradients small for everything else
effectively right because the softmax is
trying to be well it's a soft arg max
right so it's sort of saying which one
of these is like the max or you know
weight these sort of relative to how how
close they are to the max of the
function um and so if some of them are
very very large you sort of just zero
out the connections to everything that's
not being attended to that has low
probability distribution and um
[Music]
and then they don't get gradients
and so here's the size of the tension
operation we've seen okay i've taken
this is the multi-headed variant here
right because we've got the indices on
output i've got the indices on q k and v
and all i'm going to do is i'm going to
say well you know
the things that i'm about to dot
together are you know vectors of
dimensionality d over h
because of the because of the
multi-headed attention again um
and in order to stop them from growing
the dot products from growing too large
i'm just going to divide
all of my scores
so remember up here x q k top x top is a
t by t matrix of scores you're going to
divide them all by d over h
and as d grows d over h grows right
and uh and so your dot products don't
grow and this ends up being helpful as
well
okay
any questions
um yeah um john could you could you
there was an interesting question um
when you're doing um the b chord
uh attention do you only do the masking
in the first
uh in the first layer or do you do the
masking also in layer notes
yeah nice nice so um
if we were to
um
only do masking in the first layer we
would get information leakage in the
later layers
so if we look at
uh this
whoop
we if we were to look at this diagram
again right so here's the first layer of
the decoder and we've said that there's
masking right and you're able to look at
any of the encoder states and you're
only able to look at the previous words
in the decoder um in the second layer if
i'm suddenly allowed to look at all of
the future words now
hey even though i didn't in the first
layer it's just as good that i can in
the second layer and so i can just learn
to look right at what my word is
supposed to be so every single layer of
the decoder has to have that masking or
it's sort of
moot like it's as if you didn't mask it
at all effectively
thanks
okay so scale dot product in the bag
we've got it so let's look back at our
full transformer encoder decoder
framework we've looked at the encoder
blocks themselves
uh we so let's sort of expand one of
these zoom and enhance and
we've got our word embeddings position
representations and uh first we put it
through a multi-headed attention
so we've seen that
we put it through a residual layer and
layer norm so
right so you have the word embedding the
piston representations going through the
residual connection here
and also going through multi-headed
detention
add them layer norm
next you put the result of that through
a feed-forward network
uh there should be an arrow between the
feed forward and the next residual layer
but the output of this residual and
layer norm is added into that residual
and layer norm along with the output of
the feed forward
and then the output of this residual and
layer norm is the output of the
transformer encoder block
so when we had
each of these encoders here
internally each one of them was just
this and we've seen all these building
blocks before
and this is multi-headed
scaled dot product attention i omit the
scaled word
but yeah so this is this is the block
and you notice interestingly how you're
doing residual and layer norm after the
initial multihead of the tension as well
as after the feed forward
okay so so uh each one of these is just
identical right different parameters
for the different layers but uh the same
things that we've seen
now let's look at the transformer
decoder block
so this is actually more complex um in
particular you've got that masked
multi-head self-attention
and now remember this is not just for
the first one this is for all of the
transformer blocks so we've got mass
multi-headed self-attention where we
can't look at the future because we've
added negative infinity to the negative
infinity to the affinity scores
residual and layer norm like we did for
the uh for the encoder
now we've got multi-head cross attention
so this connection to the transformer
encoder
this is actually a lot like what we saw
you know in in
in
attention so far right we're attending
from the decoder to the encoder
so we actually in each transformer
decoder block we've got two different
attention functions going on
uh so we do the cross attention
we add the result of the residual and
layer norm
to the next residual and layer norm uh
along with that of the multi-head
cross-attention
okay and only after both of those
applications of attention next we do the
feed forward and residual and layer norm
where the residual is coming so the you
know x i minus one is the residual near
norm here goes into this one along with
the feed forward and so you can think of
the residual and their norm is coming
after each of the interesting things
we're doing right we're doing one
interesting thing here you know
multihead mask self-attention
cross attention after each one do
residual and layer norm help the
gradients pass etc cetera
and then the output of this residual in
layer norm is the output of the
transformer decoder
okay and so the only thing so far that
we really haven't seen in this lecture
is the multi-head cross attention and
it's i want to i want to go over it uh
it is the same equations
as the um
as the
multi-headed self-attention but the
inputs are coming from different places
and so i want to be precise about it
so let's take a look
cross attention details so um
right self-attention recall is that when
we're we're taking the keys the queries
and the values of attention from the
same information source like the same
sentence for example
and we saw last week write attention
from the decoder to the encoder so this
is going to look similar
let's do some different notation so
we're going to have h1 to ht
the output vectors from
the transformer former encoder
which are all xi in rd now remember this
is the last transformer encoder here
right you never attend to the middle
encoder blocks it's the output of the
last encoder block
so those the output vectors from the
last transformer encoder uh block and
now we have z1 to zt the input vectors
from the transformer decoder so here
maybe that is you know the input is
the word embeddings plus there is
position representations
uh or right it's actually the output of
the previous transformer decoder
right we're gonna be the inputs for the
next one
um
so uh yeah we've got our z one to z t
and we're letting them be the same
sequence length again t and t just for
simplicity
um these are also vectors z i in our d
and then the keys and the query sorry
the keys and the values are all drawn
from the encoder
right so when we're talking about
self-attention when we're talking about
attention as allowing us to sort of
access a memory
right the memory uh is
sort of what the value vectors are
encoding and the way that the values are
sort of indexed or are able to be
accessed is through the keys
and then the value and then the queries
are you know what you're
what you're using to try to look for
something right so we're looking into
the encoder as a memory and we're using
keys from the decoder to figure out
where to look for each one
so uh pictorially again
uh we can look at how cross attention is
computed in matrices like we did for
self-attention
so we've got the same thing here before
we had x now we have h these are the
encoder vectors this is going to be r t
by d
likewise we have z
notice we have two of these before
before we just had x right we had x
because x was going to be for the keys
the queries and the values now we have h
and z both are in rt by d
and the output is uh
going to be well you take your
z
for the
queries right zs we multiply by the
queries you take your h for the keys
and your h for the v's
so you are trying to take the key the
query key dot products all t squared of
them um in one matrix multiplication so
the purple is saying this is coming from
the
uh decoder the brown is saying or ish is
saying it's coming from the
uh encoder
now you've got your dot products
soft max them as you did before and now
your values are also coming from the
encoder so
again same operation different sources
for the inputs
and now you've got your output which
again is just an average of the value
vectors from the encoder
h v
the average is determined by your
weights
okay so results with transformers whoop
results with transformers
um first off was uh machine translation
so we we built our our entire encoder
decoder transformer block and you know
how does it work it works really well um
so
these are a bunch of machine translation
systems that were out when the original
attention is all you need transformers
paper came out
and
first you saw that transformers were
getting really good blue scores so this
is on the workshop on machine
translation 2014
english german and english french test
sets you get higher blue scores
which means better translations right
notice how our blue scores in this are
higher than for assignment four lots
more training data here for example
but then also not only do you get better
blue scores uh you also had uh more
efficient training
right and and uh we had a lot of tricks
that went into getting training to work
better right so you have more efficient
training here
okay so so that's a nice result that was
in the original paper
um you know past that uh there are a
number of interesting results um
summarization is one of them so here's
here's a result on summarization uh
these are sort of part of a larger
summarization system but you know you
have i liked this table because you have
sort of seek to seek with attention
which we saw before and it got
perplexity lower is better with
perplexity higher is better with rouge
on this wiki sum data set and then sort
of like
a bunch of transformer models they tried
and sort of at a certain point it
becomes transformers all the way down
and sort of the old standard of rnn sort
of falls out of practice
um and actually before too long right
transformers became dominant for
entirely different reason which is
related more to their parallelizability
because they allow you to pre-train on
just a ton of data
very quickly
and this has made them the de facto
standard so there's a lot of results
recently with transformers include
pre-training and i'm sort of
intentionally sort of excluding them
from this lecture so that you come to
the next lecture and talk and learn
about pre-training
but there's a popular aggregate
benchmark this took a bunch of very
difficult tasks and said you know
do well on all of them if you want to
score highly on our leaderboard and
you know the names of these models you
can look up if you're interested but all
of them are transformer based after
certain points the benchmark is called
glue it has a successor called super
glue everything is just transformers
after a certain sort of time
period
partly because of their pre-training
ability
okay
great so we'll discuss pre-training more
on
uh thursday
and uh
so our our transformer is it
uh like the way that we described the
attention is all you need paper so the
transformer encoder decoder we saw was
from that paper and at some point
you know we want to build new systems
what are some drawbacks and we've
already started people have already
started to build variants of
transformers that you'll go into today
and
you know it definitely has issues that
we can try to work on so
i can also take a question if anyone
wants to ask one
i mean it's back a bit that something
that there were several questions on was
the scale dot product
and the questions included
why square root of d divided by h
as opposed to just d divided by h or any
other function of d divided by h and
another one was
um
that
like why do you need that at all given
that later on you're going to use layer
norm
wow the second question is really
interesting and not one that i had
thought of before
well
right so even if the individual
components
are small so let's start with the second
question why does this matter even if
you're going to use layer norm um
you know if lara normal is averaging
everything out say make it unit standard
deviation and and uh and mean
um then actually right nothing is going
to get too small in those vectors either
so when you have a very very large
vector all with things that aren't
too small yeah
[Music]
you're still going to have
the
norm of
the dot products increase
i think
i think it's a good question i hadn't
thought about it too much that's my off
the cuff answer
but it's worth thinking about more
i think the answer is that
the effect you get of kind of losing
dynamic range as things get longer
that that's going to happen
anyway and leia norm can't fix that it's
sort of coming along too late
and
therefore you gain by doing the scaling
i think so
but i think it's worth yeah i think it's
worth thinking about more why square
root um
well let's see the norms of the dot
product grows with
o of d
and so when you square root one
no i guess the square root scales with o
of root d i can't remember there's a
little note in the attention is all you
need paper about why it's root d but i i
actually can't take it off the top of my
head here so
but it is in that paper
okay
anything else before you go on
great
um
[Music]
all right so what would you like to fix
um
you know the the thing that that shows
up most frequently as a pain point in
transformers is actually like the
quadratic compute in the self-attention
itself uh so we're having all pairs of
interactions we had that t by t matrix
that was computed by taking these dot
products between all pairs of word
vectors and so even though we argued at
the beginning of the class that we don't
have this sort of temporal dependence in
the computation graph that stops us from
parallelizing things we still need to do
all that computation and that grows
quadratically for recurrent models right
it only grew linearly every time you
applied the rnn cell uh you did sort of
more work but you're not adding
quadratically to the amount of work you
have to do as you get to longer
sequences
separately position representations i
mean the absolute position of a word is
just not
maybe not the the best way to represent
uh you know the structure of a sentence
and so there have been these two uh uh
you know among other uh advancements in
that that i don't won't be able to get
into today but you can take a look at
these papers and the papers that cite
them there are other ways to represent
position people are working on it but i
want to focus more today on the problem
of the quadratic compute so um how do we
get like how do we reason about this why
is this a problem um right so it's
highly parallelizable but we still have
to do these operations we have t squared
that's the sequence length and then d is
the dimensionality and so in computing
this matrix we have o of t squared d
computations that our gpu needs to chunk
through
um if we think of d is that around a
thousand or two or three thousand um if
we had sort of single shortish sentences
but then maybe t is like thirty ish and
then t squared is 900 so it's like ah
it's actually not that big a deal but
you know and in practice you know for a
lot of models we'll set an actual bound
like 512 so it's like if your document
is longer than 512 words you know you're
out of luck you're truncated or
something um but what if we want to work
on on on documents that are you know ten
thousand words or greater ten thousand
squared is not
is not feasible so we have to somehow
remove the dependence on t squared if
we're going to work with these
there's been a couple of ways that have
been thought of to do this this is all
very very recent work and it's only a
smattering of the efforts that have come
up so the question is can we build
models like transformers uh that get
away without the o of t squared all
pairs interactions cost
one example is the linformer and the
idea here is that
you're going to actually map the
sequence length dimension
to a lower dimensional space
for values and keys so you had values
keys and queries
and you had your normal linear layers
now you're going to project to a much
lower dimension than the sequence length
and in in doing so right
you're sort of getting rid of that t
by mapping it to something small you're
saying like just you know combine all
the information from all these time
steps into something that's lower
dimensional and so in this plot from the
paper you know as the sequence length
goes from 512 the batch size of 128 to
the sequence length being 65 000 with a
batch size of one you get the
transformer inference time sort of
growing very large and then the
linformer with various sort of
bottleneck dimensionalities ks 128 256
they're doing much much better
a separate option has been to
um
uh
kind of take a totally different take on
can we get away without these all pairs
interactions which is the following
do we need to even try to compute all
pairs of interactions if we can do sort
of a bunch of other stuff that's going
to be more efficient to compute
so like looking at local windows we know
that's useful but not sufficient in some
sense um looking at everything so if you
were to just take like an average of
vectors just all of averaging of vectors
you don't need to compute interactions
for that
and if you look at sort of random pairs
you don't need to take you know all that
much time to compute that as well and so
what this paper did is they did all of
them um so you have random attention you
have a word window attention where
you're looking at your local neighbors
and you have sort of global attention
where you're sort of you know attending
without interacting with stuff attending
broadly over the whole sequence you do a
whole bunch of it right and you end up
being able to approximate a lot of good
things
these are not you know necessarily the
answer the normal transformer variant is
by far the most popular currently but
it's a fascinating question to look into
so now as the
time
more or less expires i'll say we're
working on pre-training on thursday good
luck on assignment 4 and remember to
work on your project proposal i think we
have time for a final question if anyone
wants to
it's a good question um
yeah i
i mean
i believe still places in
reinforcement learning
i mean places where the recurrent
inductive bias is is clearly well
specified or useful um it was a
conversation like
but i don't know of places in nlp where
people are still broadly using rnns it
was thought for a while that
transformers took a lot more data to
train than rnn's and so you sort of
should use rnns on smaller data problems
but with pre-training it i'm not sure
that that's the case
i think the answer is yes there are
still use cases
um but it should be where the recurrence
seems to really uh
be the thing that is winning you
something as opposed to like
maybe needing more data or for
transformers because it seems like that
might not actually be the case even
though we thought so back in like 2017.